so chloë grace moretz his character in
this movie starts dating this dude who
has the CDs of her daggers her dad was
in a band back in the day this knowing
that not a lot of people have those CDs
and it is known that that band had a
couple groupies over in the room just
putting this out I'm just saying if I'm
being real I think Chloe grace Moretz is
character in this movie was banging her
half-brother
there it is
[Music]
if I stay so if I say he's pretty much
ghost for twins
chloë grace moretz is really good at
playing the cello she has hopes and
dreams she might get into Juilliard and
then WHAM head-on collision hit girls
having this out-of-body experience and
she's in a coma and so it's just one of
those will should I stay or should I go
not that cool though seriously this
movie alright this is my big problem
with the movie the trailer pitched it
how you think it is as I'm describing it
but it's really not like that it does
have the whole out-of-body experience
thing happening throughout the movie but
it's ultimately a container to tell the
story of how she met her boyfriend and
how they love each other in jet it's
gonna last cuz they're teenagers it
always does yeah it shows the meet it's
kind of cute they have a couple of cute
words together and it's just you see
this romance and that's what it is
they're dating and it's their romance so
you start going their separate ways
because they want different things out
of life and it's just their breakup that
was the romance then it flashes back to
her in the hospital she's like oh I had
a body experience I don't know what to
do but it does that briefly it's not the
main thing it's not like mainly she's in
the hospital and it kind of shows the
backstory it's kinda shows her in the
hospital and mainly shows his backstory
you don't care that much about it you
don't care because they're powering
through this thing I didn't even know
how long they were dating I found out
way later in the movie they were dating
for a year and a half I couldn't have
called - I thought they were dating for
like two to four months max Chloe grace
is great we all love her but Chloe grace
hazel grace it's kind of like they're
trying to just springboard off of that
jet trying to springboard off the
success of a much better movie this
movie should be called the faulted stars
of ours you know those knockoff titles
that they have on straight-to-dvd
Netflix movies because that's what this
is it feels like a hallmark movie
straight to red box it's trying to cash
in on the success of tween movies and
romances and you know heartbreaking
spoiler alert I'm going to straight-up
ruin the ending for you right here well
I'm gonna tell you what happens in the
end you can't really ruin this movie not
kind of it was really it was this movie
was boring a her family members who
were in the car wreck were just
sequentially dying throughout the movie
until she really has nothing and you're
like all right well then die when the
end of this movie her grandfather gives
her the green light to walk towards the
lie is like holding her you know
comatose hand and he's like if you want
to go I understand you have nothing left
here and she's going to and then she
doesn't why well because she loves that
dude she broke up with a couple months
ago whether or not you believe in heaven
doesn't matter point is this movie
establishes that heaven is real for this
movie so
in this movie she gave up alive an
eternity of happiness and bliss with her
dead family so she can hang out with
some 18-year old that she loves oh man
when that falls apart in about a
year that's gonna suck and that's my
point she's the main character you
should want her to live but when I'm
sitting there going yeah and I'm hoping
that the main character walks towards
the light that's not good I've now given
up on the point of this movie I'm going
the opposite direction this movie's
trying to herd me towards which means
the movie fails entirely in its goal
even the people who were running the ICU
in this movie were dicks to an
unbelievable degree I mean her friends
are trying to get in there to see her
and she's in a coma
they're like only family could be in
there and they're like well we're not
family they're like well you can't be in
there so trying to get in there to see
their friend who might died her entire
family is dead and they were close to
her family so essentially they've
experienced that loss also what are
these employees do what are these
workers these nurses do to like yeah you
get out of here I'm gonna call security
on you - security dragged her away like
oh my god there's just not like that
from my experience people who work those
positions are not actually douchebags
like that they're like oh we get it
you've experienced loss - if you can't
be in here I'm gonna explain it to you
and if you give me the puppy-dog eyes
you're probably gonna be able to get in
they're not all porn stash from oranges
the new black is what I'm trying to say
although Chloe grace Moretz was good in
her role this one just uses the whole
comb an out-of-body experience thing to
tell a boring story you don't care about
about young love which is gonna snag the
hearts of all the tweens yet if you're a
teenage girl and you're watching this
they got you there's nothing I can say I
just in about ten years you'll realize
why I'm right and you're not gonna
remember it in t-minus 10 minutes yep
already forgot we're gonna bore me with
a movie don't waste the potential of
having a ghost in it so your favorite
romance everyone has it man if you want
to be some hardened guys like I don't
like romances oh yeah you do just be
honest it's it's the Internet anonymity
is like your friend here you can say
anything whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]